good morning believe nation today's
message is don't listen to the little
man now over to Carlos cone you have to
have a vision this vision has to be
based on understanding about the
dynamics on the market globally and then
you have to pursue this vision no matter
what you have to build motivation inside
your company this is easy because you're
saying okay we want to be leader in
technology that is meaningful for the
consumer and although he some people all
the Renault people are buying into it
then we need to come to the consumer and
tell him you know tell the consumer
that's a great product which is
affordable and on top of this is going
to allow you to drive without the guilt
of the melting of the icebergs and the
change of the seasons and the
temperature etc and I think it's going
to be very powerful but again before it
starts there is always a doubt and now
we are in the period of time where a lot
of people are throwing at you a lot of
stones by saying that's not going to
work and then you have a lot of comments
from competitors saying you know you're
too much bullish is not gonna work well
obviously what you want competitors to
say is this is in the right direction
and say ok this is in the right
direction and what is your car I have no
electric cars so what what's the
situation
so what do you think I think it's
something you probably need to deal with
frequently on YouTube hate trolls people
who have an opinion that isn't really an
opinion and want to belittle you want to
put you down sometimes just for the sake
of articulating something so they can
have their voice heard it reminds me of
actually something my grandfather who's
experienced this at 86 years of age for
the last six months a man who actually
is little kept telling him he was never
gonna figure out social media and if my
grandfather at 86 wanted to run his
business he needed to hire a lot of
other people to do with social media
took my grandfather three months to
figure out Twitter and also figure out
that Twitter wasn't Facebook but he got
there with a lot of hate with a lot of
people telling him it was useless he was
wasting his time someone even told him
he was going to die before he figured it
out and he did he persevered took a heck
of a lot longer but that was the first
thing that came into mind when I thought
about entrepreneurs business and being
able to stand your own ground so now
he's doing that on Twitter
yes slowly but surely I think dealing
with haters is definitely one of the
biggest challenges that all people face
I divided them into two camps there's
the ones who don't know what they're
talking about there's the ones who have
never done what you're trying to do and
I don't get personally offended by those
people I know a lot of people and I
guess you do have to have a thick skin a
lot of people are easily offended if you
just say something really stupid or
irrelevant or just throwing out hate it
doesn't bother me I'm more concerned
with if they attack you know if I've had
a guest on my show I did a video
showcasing one of my programmers in
wishing him a happy birthday and
thanking him and people would attack him
and because he was from the Middle East
somebody called him a terrorist and this
kind of stuff and so he didn't sign up
for that right so that bothers me when
they're hating on somebody else cuz I
kind of threw them into the spotlight
and they weren't you know anticipating
to get the hate the other kind of haters
or little man is the people who do know
what they're talking about and that's
even harder to overcome I remember the
first believe video that I made I sent
to a guy who was in the video industry
and he said that no YouTube video should
be longer than six minutes and this was
like 6:18 it should be like two minutes
long and that's it and all these views
and why this video would never work
and this guy knew what it was Hawking
he's in the industry it's not like some
hater was never actually tried to make a
YouTube video before and you know what I
thought I love it I don't care I'm just
gonna put it up in the video that really
well was the first video we had to hit a
million views and keep growing a younger
less confident Evan might have listened
to him and made changes and I think
that's the biggest concern that I have
for people watching is if you have
something that you want to try something
that you're really excited interested by
even if it does fail it's still a
learning lesson for you and to not again
live with regret to say like I wish I
did it my way like I wish I gave it a
shot at least you know that it didn't
work and you find a different way to
stand and if all you do is surround
yourself with people who are hating on
your ideas and all you do is listen to
them then you're living their version of
your life instead of your own version of
it so don't listen to the little man
that's a good message I completely
support that and I think that I need to
listen to you a little bit more because
working in television we hear from a lot
of little men and big men and big women
who all have something to say all day
long and it hits you but if they aren't
part of the craft but they don't know
what they're talking about I think that
puts them in a completely different camp
as you said and maybe that's easier to
disassociate from so the question today
today is how do you get rid of the
little man or a little woman in your
life are they in your life and if so
good luck how are you getting rid of
them in your life leave in the comments
below we're gonna join the discussion
thank you so much for watching have an
amazing day continue to believe and
we'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of in spresso
we go